boa tarde bom sou do interior de são
paulo então vocês vão ouvir bastante é
puxado aí como ótimo me apresentou nome
é extensa e deixar eu a função de
encerrar depois de entrevistas palestras
que tiveram aqui ok vou tentar fazer o
meu melhor mas levamos lá bem explicar
um pouquinho a minha história porque eu
vim parar aqui jesus mãe do mundo vai
vai foi a quem bem eu sou do interior
eu tenho a voz empreendedores pais
empreendedores é a minha primeira
experiência empreendedora foi logo aos 6
anos de idade né que acontecia a minha
mãe tinha um comércio local trabalhava
junto com os meus avós e tudo mais
desvio direto no brasil bom retiro fazer
essa colega mesmo e levava as coisas pra
cidade
neco as novidades aqui de são paulo era
muito difícil tê la no interior e como
era pequena me fez a primeira proposta
assim de negócios da minha vida que ela
ela trazer brinquedinhos adesivos e
multiplicaria da 25 de março e eu vendia
na escola e eu adorava vendendo a escola
não pra ganhar dinheiro porque eu
juntava dinheiro pra nada como até hoje
eu faço eu gasto tudo enfim que eu ganho
mas eu gostava o seguinte motivo eu
gostava de tá resolvido ajudando a dor
de alguém meus amigos queriam ter
determinadas coisas que não tinham
qualquer lugar da cidade eu podia ter
podia vender entregar mais pra eles bem
a minha vida mudou muito depois do
primeiro ter becks que é o paulo tsx que
eu ir aí o primeiro palestrante né a
gente organizou duas edições nessa
cidade e eu claro e até então depois
disso tem passou eu não tive mais
experiências empreendedoras assim
aprende a natura vão enfim mas é eu
nunca sonhei em ter meu
o próprio negócio e sem querer a gente
acabou realizando mais é tão assim mas é
no tse na cabeça por um mas por que que
eu achava que eu não poderia ter o
próprio negócio queria fugir daquilo que
ia ter uma carreira
enfim a gente fundou sua primeira
estatueta para quem não conhece é como
se fosse uma empresa a gente estava lhe
dando algumas idéias ea gente toma
queria fazer alguma coisa diferente
tecnológica procurando idéias fora daqui
fora da caixa
fechando a palestra aqui do éden enfim
montamos um time complementar o time
muito bom pessoal de tecnologia bray na
parte de usabilidade
eu sempre na parte de comercial
publicidade marketing e os meninos na
uma parte de beck em enfim a gente tava
ouvindo por a empreender legal pra
caramba é fácil é só você tem um time
bom uma idéia legal e daí você presta um
concurso no acelerador a beleza você tá
rico milionário é só esperar o dinheiro
caiu na conta né pelo menos é isso que
prega por aí ok
bom a gente apresentou nossa idéia seria
primeiro tapa na cara que a gente tomou
foi na acelerador ou era né que
infelizmente não pegou a nossa empresa
para ser acelerada mas até aí a gente já
tinha largado o nosso emprego e estavam
desesperados e tudo isso a gente largou
tudo cara eu tinha um emprego
os meninos também tinham ea gente abriu
tudo porque a gente achava que a gente
ia ficar milionário de verdade entendeu
mas enfim não aconteceu a gente começou
a freqüentar mais eventos para poder
aprender mais enfim chegou na gm
nadadora não sei se vocês conhecem a com
rg mina status como o próprio nome diz é
que pega ser ideias e validam e comércio
desde o início uma estátua estava
rolando um evento lá e te investidor
anjo aqui hoje a gente já estava
conversando lógico a gente precisava de
dinheiro em nosso foco
desde que abriu a empresa era correr
atrás de dinheiro alguém que pudesse
pagar a nossa ideia alguém que pudesse
no caso a gente tava nem procurando as
empreendedoras gente inconsciente
a gente estava querendo voltar a ser
empregado alguém que sustentasse a gente
não ideia legal que a gente queria
trabalhar
enfim a gente encontrar um investidor
anjo lá ea gente tem um problema com ele
porque ele falou que ia lá é enfim
investir na nossa idéia e depois de um
tempo ok beleza ele não vai botar
dinheiro nisso a gente o nosso dinheiro
já estava acabando
a gente estava desesperado e eu comecei
meu blog
neca pela primeira vez que eu gravei o
vídeo porque porque perdemos um
investimento
eu percebi que muitas estátuas estavam
correndo atrás do rabo igual eu estava
correndo atrás no meio e esse vídeo por
fez um sucesso do caramba
muitas pessoas muitos muitos comentários
enfim o bc tem muito acesso por causa
desse vídeo porque muitas pessoas não
sabiam nem por onde começar tinham tido
o mesmo problema estava no mesmo foco
que eu enfim começou a compartilhar as
experiências de empreendedorismo ali
e aí a gente como a gente trabalhava e
como esse a gente tava achando estava as
coisas então no lugar ali por exemplo já
tinha sido vendido dois carros na
empresa mãe dos meninos
meu namoro já tinha ido para a fumaça é
enfim a gente está já estava bem mal das
pernas a gente foi lá pelo mercado para
validar nossa idéia é remota e na
esperança de tipo agora que a gente está
fazendo tudo certinho a gente achou a
bola já tá humilde gente já se ferrou
pra caramba
vou tentar estar no brasil né conseguir
uma bolsa do governo aí pra gente
continuar se mantendo enfim a gente
estava correndo atrás de dinheiro que
não era dos nossos clientes e síndico
externos enfim a gente queria ainda
continuar que alguém levasse a gente e
para o ambiente tomou a última bolada na
cara fosse agora não dá mais a gente vai
ter que parar e desistir dessa idéia é
que todo mundo fala né eu tenho uma
ideia milionária quanto que vale uma
ideia cara essa idéia e valeu o término
de namoro como eu falei dois carros 23
médio empreendedor três empreendedores
mega individados 4 frustrados e
desiludidos e trezentos e sessenta e
cinco noites mal dormidas infinitas
brigas desnecessárias
a gente brigava muito enfim
uma vez a gente caiu na real isso não
tem preço eu tenho certeza que foi a
maior lição da minha vida e dizem que se
eu tinha noite igual ao de uma criança
de um bebê corda de cinco em cinco
minutos chorando e cágado
enfim bom como é uma coisa diferente né
nessa como já estou fazendo diferente
aliás eu vou focar então agora nos
clientes do que investidores e vou
realmente encontrar uma dor para
resolver não vou criar problema na vida
de ninguém tentar enfiar uma solução que
não existe para as pessoas comprar
validar um produto antes de investir meu
tempo e dinheiro nele e sem métrica de
vaidade pelo amor de deus
o lac no facebook a sesa não significam
nada o que significa dinheiro na mão e
dinheiro de cliente
bem aí eu encontrei ebrahim e o edu que
são os fundadores da bomba num evento
que eu tava de gerente de gerente a eu
tava gerente de operações desse evento e
administrei 249 startup nesse evento
estava lá o edu coimbra aí estamos
contratando uma pessoa porque eles já
tinham uma ideia validada se trata de
market place onde você pode contratar
faxineiras online
eu fui lá focar trabalhar com vocês eu
quero um pouco ilegal está dando certo e
nem a gente estava ele estava um treino
acho que coisas de 15 faxinas por semana
algo a fim e eu entrei ea gente e eu
descobri que esse trabalho não só
resolver a vida das pessoas que precisam
de faxineira mas também resolvi a vida
de muitas mulheres
essas mulheres são muito batalhadora
cara e eu acho que a minha força de
continuar trabalhando no bumba é por
elas né
imagina só que uma mulher dessa não tira
nem mil reais hoje para sustentar filho
pra pegar a condução e trabalhar enfim e
hoje com a bomba tem mulher que tira
mais de três mil reais por mês
então a gente não só muda a vida das
pessoas e resolve o problema como a
gente transforma a vida dessas mulheres
bom enfim nosso mapa já está muito maior
do que esse tão pouco desatualizado
essas são as mulheres sobra
a cidade de são paulo hoje a gente está
em 19 cidades no brasil e esses são os
nossos clientes mas enfim também já está
muito maior do que isso
e qual é a métrica que a gente vai
utilizar daqui pra frente ea métrica que
todo mundo que quer fazer um negócio é
possível sim fazer um negócio que mude o
mundo é a métrica de elogio que você
realmente está fazendo diferença na vida
das pessoas e esse daí o time quando
estava menorzinho a gente já está em 11
pessoas
mel é o terceiro entrar e agora já
estamos em 11
e esses são meus contatos pessoal é é
isso brigado